Caption: hello everyone my name is rob curley and
Caption: it's an absolute pleasure to be with you
Caption: today
Caption: and welcome to your first breakout
Caption: session of ddd perth 2021
Caption: and in this session we'll be exploring
Caption: what it takes to think like a cto
Caption: so many of the talks that you'll see
Caption: today will cover the myriad new
Caption: technologies architectures products and
Caption: frameworks that we have available to use
Caption: this talk's going to be a little bit
Caption: different we're going to be looking at
Caption: how we give technology purpose how we
Caption: can derive value from it and how we can
Caption: assess its suitability to delivering a
Caption: user or business outcomes
Caption: and the agenda for the next 45 minutes
Caption: together
Caption: it's a little bit ambitious we're going
Caption: to start with a not so gentle primer uh
Caption: strategy
Caption: what's involved this is great thinking
Caption: tools we have
Caption: and the other areas pertaining to
Caption: being creating a set of decisions of
Caption: folklore
Caption: within your business for kind of
Caption: defining how you'll win
Caption: we'll also look at personal growth so
Caption: the techniques that you can bring back
Caption: to your company on monday and start
Caption: applying instantly so whether you be in
Caption: a leadership role or not
Caption: and we're going to look at technology
Caption: strategy from three main perspectives
Caption: first of all we'll look at its purpose
Caption: how it relates to broader strategic
Caption: goals
Caption: with this base level of understanding
Caption: established were they gonna pivot to how
Caption: to define
Caption: communicate and evolve a technology
Caption: strategy
Caption: and finally we're going to look at
Caption: making decisions one of the critical
Caption: parts of any strategy how do you turn
Caption: ideas into decisions and ultimately
Caption: actions that will yield positive
Caption: outcomes for your users or customers
Caption: so a little bit about myself i am the
Caption: head of engineering at fixed technology
Caption: and at fix we build transport solutions
Caption: for entire cities
Caption: so if you're familiar with the mikey
Caption: card in melbourne that was one of the
Caption: previous solutions that we've delivered
Caption: before that i was a principal consultant
Caption: at telstra purple where i worked with
Caption: ctos and cios on defining companies
Caption: strategic technology strategies
Caption: i am also a member of the ddd perth
Caption: committee and i am in absolute awe of my
Caption: fellow committee members and the
Caption: incredible work they put in to bring
Caption: events like this to the community
Caption: and i'm also available at rob d crowley
Caption: on the socials
Caption: and i do have a confession to make
Caption: i absolutely love shy d-tech
Caption: but in today's talk i really hope that i
Caption: can change your perspective about tech
Caption: technology just a little bit
Caption: and be able to give you the tools to
Caption: assess whether it's viable whether it's
Caption: the correct choice for the problem at
Caption: hand and the outcome you're looking to
Caption: achieve for your customers
Caption: so i've used that word strategy quite a
Caption: few times already
Caption: so what is strategy
Caption: the one in doubt consult a dictionary
Caption: and our friends at macquarie dictionary
Caption: tell us that strategy is a plan of
Caption: action
Caption: designed to achieve a long-term aim
Caption: so we can see a couple of things from
Caption: this definition
Caption: first we can see it's about making
Caption: decisions and acting upon them
Caption: and secondly that this activity is
Caption: performed to achieve a long-term vision
Caption: i've just done it again i've introduced
Caption: a new word vision and often
Caption: vision mission purpose
Caption: strategy all of these words are used
Caption: interchangeably in conversations which
Caption: creates a really muddied picture of what
Caption: we're looking to achieve
Caption: so let's break them down
Caption: so what is a company's purpose what's
Caption: its vision what's its mission
Caption: the purpose is really the why
Caption: why does the company exist
Caption: and at vixx our purpose is to connect
Caption: people and places
Caption: it forms our true north
Caption: the vision it's a statement of intent
Caption: it's the lighthouse
Caption: it then
Caption: marks the statement of intent on the
Caption: positive impact you will make on the
Caption: world so how will the world different
Caption: once you have delivered your work
Caption: the mission is the how so to achieve the
Caption: vision you need to do some concrete set
Caption: of actions
Caption: and this is where strategy comes in
Caption: the strategy uses the mission
Caption: to achieve the vision
Caption: and that's very important to be able to
Caption: break them down because the mission
Caption: should be concrete it should be
Caption: actionable it should be measurable
Caption: and that then forms the core of the
Caption: strategy so if you're thinking back
Caption: actually i'm not the person who sets my
Caption: company's purpose or my vision don't
Caption: worry
Caption: you can still define an incredible
Caption: strategy that leverages the mission to
Caption: achieve the vision
Caption: and the first thing we need to realize
Caption: about strategy is it cannot live or
Caption: exist in a vacuum
Caption: without context it is impossible to
Caption: discern decisions or actions which are
Caption: harmful or beneficial to the outcomes
Caption: you're looking to achieve
Caption: we need to look at the context and the
Caption: environment to which we operate
Caption: and this ability is called situational
Caption: awareness and this is table stakes for
Caption: effective strategy
Caption: and this is how we can perceive
Caption: assimilate and synthesize inputs from
Caption: the context in which we operate
Caption: and in this context the environment is
Caption: the
Caption: the operating context so the industry
Caption: your organization your competitors all
Caption: form part of this environment
Caption: and this is in a constant state of flux
Caption: and you can't control this flux
Caption: there's a global pandemic which has
Caption: undermined many companies strategies
Caption: a competitor could launch a new product
Caption: that could be a new technology
Caption: innovation that radically changes the
Caption: environment which you operate
Caption: this is in constant flux so for example
Caption: the global pandemic was a financial boom
Caption: for companies such as zoom who offer
Caption: video conferencing conversely it hit
Caption: wework's strategic plan very heavily
Caption: it still has all of the contracts on its
Caption: side with the landlords but its own
Caption: internal occupancy plummeted
Caption: so through no fault of the road a
Caption: strategy that could previously have been
Caption: effective
Caption: has been undermined or changed radically
Caption: and the ticketing industry is no
Caption: different
Caption: the rise of covert has driven cash out
Caption: of a system so contactless or emv being
Caption: able to pay for travel with your smart
Caption: cards has become predominant
Caption: but this is only the status we can
Caption: already see a passion emerging whereby
Caption: the ticketing industry will likely not
Caption: remain standalone for long you could see
Caption: it being integrated with other services
Caption: such as parking possibly towards smart
Caption: cities and
Caption: single account based government accounts
Caption: and you can see all of these things
Caption: extrapolate based on this one large
Caption: change to the environment
Caption: and there's a key point to make as well
Caption: is that competition drives evolution
Caption: or to restate it without competition
Caption: stagnation will result
Caption: and companies respond to
Caption: changes in the environment at different
Caption: paces
Caption: so if you take compute for instance
Caption: previously we would have had our own
Caption: data centers that we would have named
Caption: our servers cute little things like star
Caption: wars characters or simpsons characters
Caption: but then
Caption: some companies early on
Caption: said actually we can then use them as
Caption: cattle not pets and they adopted i as so
Caption: ec2
Caption: but that was only the start of it with
Caption: the advent of serverless with
Caption: pay-as-you-go that has gone from being a
Caption: differentiator right the way through to
Caption: a commodity just like electricity
Caption: and as william gibson said the future's
Caption: already here is just unevenly
Caption: distributed
Caption: and companies respond to change
Caption: differently
Caption: but you sometimes think the fastest will
Caption: be the most successful
Caption: let's turn the clock back to the early
Caption: 1990s and look at a case where being
Caption: first is not necessarily a precursor for
Caption: success
Caption: so back in the early 90s netscape had
Caption: about an 80 market share of the browser
Caption: space
Caption: and it had a single product which is
Caption: charged for customers and a lot of good
Caption: will towards it
Caption: microsoft looking at this
Caption: look back maybe we don't need to take
Caption: the first risk of foray into this
Caption: particular product space because they
Caption: knew that they had a 90
Caption: marker penetration in desktop operating
Caption: systems so what did they do
Caption: they bundled internet explorer for free
Caption: so they had huge leverage in terms of
Caption: their existing sales channels
Caption: and we were also in a case where
Caption: customers users suddenly gaining access
Caption: to
Caption: the internet
Caption: was life-changing but it was also in a
Caption: stage where they weren't incredibly
Caption: savvy in terms of the differences or the
Caption: nuances between one product and another
Caption: and so what we saw there is
Caption: microsoft ultimately won that with very
Caption: little competition
Caption: and internet explorer became the
Caption: predominant browser
Caption: but at the end of that first browser war
Caption: with no competition
Caption: internet explorer stopped progressing it
Caption: stagnated and ultimately gave rise to
Caption: chrome's ascendancy some years later
Caption: and apple we often think of apple
Caption: i have multiple apple devices been the
Caption: most innovative company in the world if
Caption: you look at their strategy it's
Caption: fundamentally based on being a fast
Caption: follower
Caption: they look at something that someone has
Caption: done before they do it better they think
Caption: about the experience around it
Caption: but whether you have to be the disruptor
Caption: at the
Caption: the start or
Caption: the fast follower it a lot depends on
Caption: your market position
Caption: so if you have the ability to out
Caption: deliver a competitor so if you're a big
Caption: four bank you might look at a fintech or
Caption: a deal bank
Caption: that could be an effective strategy one
Caption: one strategy as well would be to acquire
Caption: but if you can not out build or out
Caption: deliver your competitor a fast follower
Caption: strategy is doomed to fail
Caption: there's another aspect that i'd like to
Caption: explore as well and i'll introduce the
Caption: kano model and this is typically used to
Caption: prioritize features on a product roadmap
Caption: based on the degree that they're likely
Caption: to satisfy
Caption: a customer need
Caption: and we will have certain
Caption: features certain capabilities that will
Caption: be attractive such that if you fulfill
Caption: them you will get disproportionate
Caption: goodwill and market leverage
Caption: but then there are other features which
Caption: are considered must-haves
Caption: so you wind the clock back if you use
Caption: facial recognition on your phone that
Caption: was absolutely an attractive feature but
Caption: now it's becoming commonplace if you
Caption: don't have it customers will not buy
Caption: your product it will no longer be the
Caption: differentiator for customers to go out
Caption: and choose yours
Caption: and there was a trend here that over
Caption: time
Caption: attractive features
Caption: become must-haves
Caption: the market moves
Caption: and it's the same with technology
Caption: the novel becomes commonplace and in
Caption: turn enables the creation of more
Caption: complex innovations
Caption: the commonplace enables the novel
Caption: so again the commodification of storage
Caption: and compute it's not just about that and
Caption: doing pay as you go in turn that has
Caption: given rise to innovations with big data
Caption: machine learning that would previously
Caption: have been unattainable
Caption: so again it's looking at cycles and
Caption: understanding that in your business
Caption: there will always be phases that have
Caption: some areas where you want to break new
Caption: ground
Caption: and other areas where you just want to
Caption: stabilize
Caption: and the key thing is we have to use
Caption: appropriate methods for the domain at
Caption: hand so if you use a one-size-fits-all
Caption: approach across your entire organization
Caption: it will be sub-optimal by definition you
Caption: will have some areas of your business
Caption: where you want to disproportionately
Caption: invest and innovate and others which you
Caption: want to stabilize
Caption: so is there again some prior art that we
Caption: could look at around this so kent beck
Caption: you might know him from
Caption: his days at chrysler and xp
Caption: but while he was at facebook he created
Caption: a model called 3x which is three-way
Caption: phases explore expanded extract
Caption: so on the y-axis we have payoff and
Caption: that's success from a business
Caption: perspective
Caption: are we making money is it succeeding is
Caption: it good for the business
Caption: and on the x-axis we have customer
Caption: success is it delighting customers and
Caption: we are looking for win-win scenarios
Caption: and when we begin we're looking for
Caption: product market fit we're exploring we're
Caption: building to learn
Caption: as we gain attraction we get more
Caption: customers but they're looking to expand
Caption: so we're looking at making it scale
Caption: and finally we're looking at extracting
Caption: so how do we make the most money the
Caption: most value of this
Caption: while still keeping that customer
Caption: satisfaction
Caption: and our focus changes at different
Caption: points
Caption: so at the beginning we're looking to
Caption: eliminate uncertainty
Caption: what's a good delivery method for that
Caption: agile feedback loops
Caption: but in the center stage we're then
Caption: looking at expanding so in this case
Caption: we're looking to eliminate waste because
Caption: any waste in our operating model will be
Caption: magnified based on the number of
Caption: customers we have
Caption: so in this space actually lean
Caption: techniques are incredibly powerful so
Caption: looking at forms of buddha and
Caption: eliminating waste whereas right up at
Caption: the right hand side you might just have
Caption: an incredibly stable offering but you
Caption: want to eliminate variability
Caption: so again structures from there like six
Caption: sigma which have a focus on reducing
Caption: defects is incredibly powerful
Caption: so again understanding what methods to
Caption: apply and when
Caption: is incredibly important to be able to
Caption: define the focus and the leverage points
Caption: in your systems as well
Caption: so if anyone says to you
Caption: agile is universally better than x or
Caption: don't use white you have to understand
Caption: the context and you have to understand
Caption: what you're looking to achieve at that
Caption: point in time
Caption: and there's also a corollary that our
Caption: risk appetite over time decreases
Caption: so at the start we're building to learn
Caption: we're looking for a fit and if it
Caption: doesn't work that's fine we haven't
Caption: invested that much
Caption: but if we have a large number of
Caption: customers
Caption: a huge amount of investment
Caption: that again our risk appetite slides
Caption: considerably
Caption: so again being aware when you talk about
Caption: products and teams what is the operating
Caption: context in terms of your offerings
Caption: we talked about decisions
Caption: but decisions without actions are
Caption: pointless
Caption: but at the same time we have to be
Caption: distilling information to make sure that
Caption: the actions we take are well reasoned
Caption: and this is possibly the single most
Caption: important thing that we will talk about
Caption: today
Caption: and this is the ooda loop by john boyd
Caption: so a former
Caption: u.s fighter pilot and a lot of the
Caption: material that i'm presenting today have
Caption: its origins back in the work that john
Caption: boyd has done
Caption: and in it he defines a loop for critical
Caption: decision making
Caption: and we and we start with observation so
Caption: again that's looking at the environment
Caption: and sensing outside circumstances that
Caption: can be
Caption: new technology launches competitors
Caption: launch a rival product
Caption: changes in again outbreaks i don't think
Caption: that could affect your business from
Caption: there
Caption: the next stage is orientate so again
Caption: based on that input information how
Caption: should we respond where do we position
Caption: ourselves how does that change our model
Caption: of the world
Caption: then finally you look at hypotheses what
Caption: can you do based on this new information
Caption: and base of those hypotheses you then
Caption: select options
Caption: and once you have selected an option you
Caption: then act so test probe and implement
Caption: using doctrine so doctrine being your
Caption: how in terms of simon's civics golden
Caption: circle it's the secret source that built
Caption: up experience and processes in your
Caption: company
Caption: and the quicker you can do this
Caption: the more quickly you'll be able to adapt
Caption: to changes in your environment
Caption: and the key takeaway is the strategy is
Caption: not a linear process but an iterative
Caption: cycle
Caption: you cannot create the best strategy at a
Caption: point in time but have it as a guarantee
Caption: for future success
Caption: it's constantly being able to refine as
Caption: an adapted based on new information
Caption: coming in and then being able to cheaply
Caption: validate those hypotheses
Caption: so strategy
Caption: it's really an informed opinion about
Caption: how to win
Caption: there is an element of a crystal ball to
Caption: it but again you're looking to
Caption: assimilate that information and then
Caption: based on those beliefs in those actions
Caption: that your company will see future
Caption: success
Caption: it requires an iterative approach with
Caption: high context feedback loops
Caption: and competition is constantly driving
Caption: change in your environment if you want
Caption: to really begin your journey in terms of
Caption: defining strategies
Caption: learning that broader context both
Caption: within and outside your company and
Caption: industry is incredibly valuable
Caption: situational awareness is the primary
Caption: capability you need and that's actually
Caption: sums up what i just described as well
Caption: and leveraging models such as the ooda
Caption: loop
Caption: and 3x there's numerous others so i have
Caption: in the slide deck i've shared many more
Caption: models as well that i haven't presented
Caption: to you today
Caption: but then also strategic thinking is a
Caption: skill and like any skill is subject to
Caption: the dreyfus model of skills acquisition
Caption: we will start as novices and at some
Caption: point we may attain mastery but it will
Caption: take time and dedication
Caption: so with that let's turn our attention to
Caption: technology strategy and again let's
Caption: start with a quick definition so
Caption: technology strategy
Caption: a collective set of decisions
Caption: around the use of technology and related
Caption: factors to achieve a business or end
Caption: user outcome
Caption: key takeaway is an effective technology
Caption: strategy amplifies your business
Caption: strategy
Caption: if it does not improve the primary
Caption: outcomes your business are looking to
Caption: achieve that is not a good technology
Caption: strategy
Caption: so any of the measures that you have
Caption: around it should be anchored in the user
Caption: needs or the business outcomes you are
Caption: looking to
Caption: achieve and in terms of defining it
Caption: going long form in a document and
Caption: writing the technology strategy down
Caption: is vital to making it accessible
Caption: i was actually a little bit unconvinced
Caption: about this until i i did a consulting
Caption: gig while i was at telstra purple at
Caption: bankwest
Caption: and we did quite a number of activities
Caption: for in terms of defining the technology
Caption: strategy for apis for data for analytics
Caption: and the level of engagement that
Caption: garnered and increased understanding
Caption: across the development teams was
Caption: extraordinary
Caption: and
Caption: we're going to go through this section
Caption: reasonably quickly so for two reasons
Caption: there's a ton of material that i will
Caption: link in the resources slide at the end
Caption: but there's also information that's
Caption: probably best learned and dissected by
Caption: yourself as well but we'll go through
Caption: the quick cliff notes so you get an idea
Caption: about the various
Caption: concepts involved
Caption: so possibly oddly we start a technology
Caption: strategy by not talking about technology
Caption: we anchor it in the business need
Caption: so what is the technical strategy
Caption: that would need to exist to support the
Caption: business and to do that you need to
Caption: understand the business context first so
Caption: that's where we start
Caption: from there we define the tech landscape
Caption: so what does it look like in your
Caption: organization today the idea here is to
Caption: build empathy what are the constraints
Caption: what are the challenges that you're
Caption: facing
Caption: can you go full
Caption: serverless architecture well no rob i
Caption: have a mainframe over here what are we
Caption: going to do about that so it's again
Caption: making sure that we can build a
Caption: technology strategy that's realistic
Caption: that references the truth in the
Caption: organization at that point in time
Caption: but we also need to set america on a
Caption: hill a vision of where we want to be
Caption: and this defines the intended direction
Caption: and the actions that are going to be
Caption: taken to achieve that it might be
Caption: breaking down the monolith it might be
Caption: using strangler patterns to abstract the
Caption: painful areas of your architecture it
Caption: might be embracing distributed
Caption: communication and messaging there could
Caption: be many things that you could involve
Caption: but this is again
Caption: building those principles that will then
Caption: get your architecture or your technology
Caption: strategy from a
Caption: to b
Caption: and then there's the principles and
Caption: guardrails to enable effective
Caption: distributed decision making whenever
Caption: we're looking at a technology strategy
Caption: your goal should be how do i give the
Caption: teams at the edge the context to make
Caption: good decisions
Caption: rather than trying to centralize
Caption: thinking into a
Caption: centralized architecture team or similar
Caption: and being able to define principles and
Caption: guarantees are key for that
Caption: so let's take a look at this
Caption: so i'll share an example from myob
Caption: created by their former cto simon reich
Caption: allen and and their platform manifesto
Caption: was written in a very similar way to the
Caption: agile manifesto
Caption: and they talk about
Caption: the medium-term decisions over
Caption: short-term thinking stable technologies
Caption: over the unproven
Caption: existing assets overdue development
Caption: and there's a couple of things we can
Caption: learn from this
Caption: actually remember that expand extract
Caption: model that i showed before 3x a lot of
Caption: where myob are a stable mature business
Caption: they've already gone through the
Caption: eliminating uncertainty and they're
Caption: looking to eliminate waste in their
Caption: systems now they're looking to be able
Caption: to scale out their platform and what
Caption: they give you the guidance their teams
Caption: is to encourage decisions and actions
Caption: which are not about hitting an immediate
Caption: goal but the long-term sustainability of
Caption: their platform
Caption: then also documenting what your
Caption: technology radar or scope is and making
Caption: it visible to all the teams
Caption: so again with a couple of clients i have
Caption: worked with a build your own radar by
Caption: thoughtworks um again it's worked really
Caption: well in some places not another so again
Caption: use it with your own discretion your
Caption: mileage may vary but in terms of
Caption: visualizing across the teams
Caption: what matters and what's current in terms
Caption: of adopt or trial or assess within your
Caption: organization can be incredibly powerful
Caption: one word of warning though is have a lot
Caption: of thought at the start about the level
Caption: of fidelity that you want to go to
Caption: including every single library used by
Caption: every single team will create a huge
Caption: amount of noise very little value and
Caption: the last part of that is documenting
Caption: decisions
Caption: so if you're familiar with the
Caption: architecture decision records pattern
Caption: it's very similar it's about clearly
Caption: articulating what you want to achieve in
Caption: your changes
Caption: in your technology decisions assessing
Caption: options as they pertain to the success
Caption: criteria and they're also defining why
Caption: you chose a certain option
Caption: and that might be we would have loved to
Caption: choose option a
Caption: but for time pressures or cost pressures
Caption: or skills within the team we have chosen
Caption: a different option
Caption: and that's about building empathy for
Caption: the next people who join the team to
Caption: understand why you're in a current
Caption: situation and it's incredibly valuable
Caption: learning material for when someone joins
Caption: your team
Caption: and remember strategy is iterative treat
Caption: this technology strategy document in the
Caption: same way donate for perfection on the
Caption: first pass
Caption: time box it so what i did at bankwest i
Caption: think we did four weeks
Caption: so we did a whole lot of interviews and
Caption: then shipped it for feedback that
Caption: improved over a couple of iterations
Caption: and the key thing is
Caption: share it with people during their
Caption: inductions when someone joins your team
Caption: walk them through that document treat it
Caption: as a living artifact so building a
Caption: review process every three months is it
Caption: still current is it still adding value
Caption: to the teams
Caption: so a couple of takeaways
Caption: so a technology strategy should amplify
Caption: the business or user outcomes
Caption: and defining a long-form technology
Caption: strategy documents is an excellent way
Caption: of doing things
Caption: and just like strategy and initiative
Caption: process the technology strategy should
Caption: be defined in the same way
Caption: and ensure the technology strategy is
Caption: visible it will only add value if it's
Caption: visible and it's embedded in the
Caption: onboarding process across addie t
Caption: okay probably my favorite section of
Caption: this talk so metrics how do you actually
Caption: measure if you're going in the right
Caption: direction
Caption: so situational awareness incredibly
Caption: powerful
Caption: but user needs cannot be
Caption: best by just becoming aware of them
Caption: that would be a think tank we have to be
Caption: able to make actions and deliver upon
Caption: them
Caption: and i'll
Caption: read you you're not going to find this
Caption: in macquarie this is my personal
Caption: definition of a metric and there's a few
Caption: things that would like to point you your
Caption: attention to so it's a quantifiable
Caption: measure of the performance of a business
Caption: or a component of your business
Caption: and a change in the metric should inform
Caption: whether the existing course of behavior
Caption: should be continued or adjusted
Caption: so a metric is only valuable if it
Caption: drives behavior within your organization
Caption: and a metric can be applied to an
Caption: application
Caption: a business department people process
Caption: system but it needs to drive behavior
Caption: and let's see how that might work in
Caption: practice so if we have an evolutionary
Caption: system we will get at the start
Caption: at any point in time we will have a
Caption: number of options that are presented to
Caption: us so to say we're going through the
Caption: ooda loop we're assessing these options
Caption: and then we decide
Caption: so as we continue down and we test and
Caption: we learn are these improving our core
Caption: measures if they are that we take them
Caption: as successful candidates
Caption: and we can then move to point b if they
Caption: are not achieving the outcomes we would
Caption: wish to see then we have to change
Caption: course change direction
Caption: so metrics act as that guiding light of
Caption: if you're doing the right thing within
Caption: your business
Caption: and again at any point in time we have
Caption: multiple options
Caption: using effective metrics to guide our
Caption: path through to some arbitrary end and
Caption: of course with an evolutionary system
Caption: there is no end but this is why being
Caption: able to have a quantifiable measure is
Caption: incredibly important
Caption: but again the measure is only the start
Caption: it's being able to align your behavior
Caption: to it
Caption: so i think i probably said metric two
Caption: dozen times already and i said they're
Caption: really important
Caption: but how should you go about choosing
Caption: a good metric how do you find these
Caption: things that will guide you towards
Caption: success
Caption: first
Caption: don't start with a metric
Caption: that's the key piece of advice so
Caption: a metric should be at output so
Caption: if you want to begin again you go back
Caption: to your work on monday figure out what's
Caption: important to your organization
Caption: what's one of your goals
Caption: and then think of a couple of ways that
Caption: you might got to satisfy that goal
Caption: move the needle on one of them
Caption: then what work would need to be done
Caption: might be there might be an existing team
Caption: looking to progress one of those goals
Caption: and again ideally start executing that
Caption: initiative it's only at this point once
Caption: you have done those first three steps
Caption: that you should really think about a
Caption: measure or a metric
Caption: and the good metric will be one to say
Caption: whether they're making progress
Caption: and the single most important question
Caption: you can ask yourself when you're
Caption: defining a metric or throughout this
Caption: process is is this work allied with the
Caption: user
Caption: need and a good metric will be what that
Caption: matters what that matters to your users
Caption: or customers that you can do something
Caption: about that's actionable that you could
Caption: change behavior around it and that
Caption: reflects your business performance
Caption: so more broadly if we go to ankara
Caption: metrics based on customers you can look
Caption: at dave mcclure's pirate metrics which
Caption: then map each phase of a customer as
Caption: they might relate to your business
Caption: so we can start with acquisition so how
Caption: do users find you you might have certain
Caption: metrics about how do you bring people to
Caption: your product
Caption: once they found you how do you sign them
Caption: up how do you give an excellent first
Caption: experience to them
Caption: that is about retention so once they've
Caption: used your product once how do you keep
Caption: them coming back how do you continue to
Caption: deliver value for them
Caption: with referral how do you turn these
Caption: users into advocates for your product
Caption: how do they tell others
Caption: then how do you make money from them
Caption: i should point out that these are a
Caption: guiding light to be able to categorize
Caption: where your users are and then think
Caption: about questions or goals you would have
Caption: and ultimately define the metrics off of
Caption: them these are not sequential so you
Caption: might have an area where revenue is
Caption: actually incredibly important to your
Caption: business you might immediately after
Caption: activation then you're caring about
Caption: revenue and then later you might be
Caption: caring about growth
Caption: so in this particular sequence i have
Caption: said that growth is really important so
Caption: i'm looking for market share and then
Caption: money and income is based on scale not
Caption: the percentage income per user
Caption: but being able to define metrics like
Caption: this requires a certain level of data
Caption: informed decisions amongst your business
Caption: so again this is something i do need to
Caption: call out here so in my
Caption: multiple years of consulting
Caption: i have seen many organizations struggle
Caption: with this because you can't suddenly
Caption: start generating customer insights it
Caption: needs to start with data and data needs
Caption: to be categorized cleansed synthesized
Caption: into information and then once you
Caption: catalog this information you can
Caption: generate insights from it
Caption: and most companies don't capture the
Caption: data they would need to make informed
Caption: decisions so example in a in a banking
Caption: app
Caption: at bankwest we saw that when a customer
Caption: changed their name we didn't do anything
Caption: about it we just saved it
Caption: but a customer could change their name
Caption: for multiple reasons they could be
Caption: getting married they could be getting
Caption: divorced how you would respond to that
Caption: from a business context is incredibly
Caption: different
Caption: but again if you just do it at a crud
Caption: operation you lose a lot of that
Caption: valuable context to understand how you
Caption: should respond to it
Caption: so again whenever you're building your
Caption: systems think about not what you're
Caption: doing in terms of a data change but the
Caption: intent behind that because that will
Caption: then yield far greater insights down the
Caption: line
Caption: and simon wardley so the man behind
Caption: wardley maps
Caption: he has also defined a set of doctrines
Caption: so universal best practices irrespective
Caption: of your industry things that we should
Caption: be doing to improve the ongoing success
Caption: of our business
Caption: so again universal patterns
Caption: and if we looked in the worlds of
Caption: metrics can we find universal metrics
Caption: that irrespective of your industry that
Caption: are valuable to follow
Caption: and i feel there are
Caption: so in the work by nicole forsgren jess
Caption: humble and gene kim and accelerate
Caption: they've defined four devops state of the
Caption: union metrics
Caption: and just before we go a little bit
Caption: further so devops it's a set of
Caption: practices that work to automate and
Caption: integrate the processes between software
Caption: and i t teams so they can learn faster
Caption: you might see other things to go so they
Caption: can really software better it's not it's
Caption: actually about amplifying feedback loops
Caption: so again being able to increase the
Caption: speed or cadence with which you can
Caption: release software allow you to build your
Caption: situational awareness
Caption: but the four metrics they've defined are
Caption: as follows so deployment frequency we
Caption: want the higher the number as possible
Caption: lead time for change we want this to be
Caption: as short as possible so the time from
Caption: when we go to idea to production
Caption: we want mean time to recover to be as
Caption: low as possible so when we have a server
Caption: out is how do we minimize the impact to
Caption: our customers and again fail change rate
Caption: we want that to be as low as possible as
Caption: well so i'm actually going to group
Caption: these so i'd say the first two as being
Caption: speed focused and the second two being
Caption: stability focused
Caption: so again let's plot this on a graph so
Caption: on the y-axis let's look at speed of
Caption: productivity and on the x-axis we'll
Caption: look at quality and stability and we'll
Caption: plot our metrics on it
Caption: and i will now introduce to you
Caption: crowley's non-scientific code of
Caption: balanced behavior
Caption: so what we are looking at from here is
Caption: as an organization with your risk
Caption: appetite how fast do you want to go so
Caption: are you actually comfortable increasing
Caption: your change frequency at the cost of
Caption: maybe a slight increase to your failed
Caption: change rate
Caption: so again being able to define these
Caption: metrics that are actually in positive
Caption: tension with each other to then create
Caption: balanced behavior within your teams
Caption: and in this model based on your risk
Caption: appetite and maturity it is absolutely
Caption: possible to have both speed and quality
Caption: but success is far from guaranteed let's
Caption: look at a couple of examples where you
Caption: can go wrong with metrics because it is
Caption: a path paved in tears
Caption: the first is creating metrics that only
Caption: focus on avoiding errors how many people
Caption: have a measure within your organization
Caption: that says number of p ones in the last
Caption: quarter
Caption: oh there's a few isn't there i actually
Caption: think that's a shocking measure right to
Caption: be honest the only thing that's going to
Caption: drive teams to do is release less
Caption: because when you do a release it injects
Caption: entropy into your environment and the
Caption: chance of an incident increases so if
Caption: that's the only thing you're measuring
Caption: your teams on it will atrophy change you
Caption: need to balance it with a productivity
Caption: metric as well that encourages teams to
Caption: go
Caption: faster
Caption: so again don't build metrics on avoiding
Caption: errors build metrics on achieving
Caption: excellence
Caption: there's also one of my favorites so the
Caption: cobra effect and this is defining a
Caption: metric that is has an intent of
Caption: improving a situation but actually does
Caption: the complete opposite these are known as
Caption: perverse incentives so let's look at an
Caption: example
Caption: so back in the 1990s in new york and
Caption: pennsylvania they
Caption: the health department started publishing
Caption: stats around patients doing culinary
Caption: bypasses and the idea was that if you
Caption: then publish that information about
Caption: doctors who have the highest success
Caption: rates in this case or lowest mortality
Caption: rates that you would then see
Caption: the better doctors getting more of the
Caption: work and the doctors with a poor record
Caption: getting less it makes sense win for the
Caption: doctor win for the patients
Caption: what we actually saw was that doctors
Caption: stopped
Caption: operating on really sick people
Caption: because really sick people have the
Caption: unfortunate habit of
Caption: dying
Caption: and that's absolutely horrible because
Caption: it's the exact opposite of the intent of
Caption: that metric but again it's like i
Caption: defined before the metric only measured
Caption: what axes of behavior and did not create
Caption: a balanced situation
Caption: the great hanoi rap massacre is another
Caption: famous example of campbell's law in
Caption: action
Caption: we also have vanity metrics so metrics
Caption: that depict the rosiest picture possible
Caption: but they'll accurately reflect the key
Caption: drivers of your business
Caption: so unless you're
Caption: making money from ad impressions then
Caption: total page counts or total hits is
Caption: likely not going to be successful
Caption: cargo cult metrics
Caption: choosing metrics of popular companies
Caption: because they are successful even if that
Caption: context does not map to your own
Caption: i'm doing it because a successful
Caption: company is doing it all we're doing is
Caption: imitating
Caption: and we're substituting imitation for
Caption: understanding and it's a beguiling
Caption: shortcut but it is one that is fraught
Caption: in peril because you don't understand if
Caption: those are actually aligned to your
Caption: business drivers
Caption: measuring outputs is one of the worst
Caption: lines of code delivered by a developer
Caption: total number of pull requests reviewed
Caption: so things are outputs and not outcomes
Caption: these just create noise and add very
Caption: little value across the board
Caption: possibly one of the most evil weaponized
Caption: metrics and this is using metrics for
Caption: comparison and punishment rather than
Caption: for continuous improvement you might
Caption: often see this from another department
Caption: head saying why have you increased your
Caption: fail change rate so why can't you
Caption: deliver on time
Caption: so these are particularly toxic
Caption: behaviors that you can see
Caption: and again there's a law for everything
Caption: this is actually an example of
Caption: goodheart's law which states that any
Caption: observed statistical regularity will
Caption: tend to collapse once pressure is placed
Caption: upon it for control purposes or another
Caption: way of saying is
Caption: when a measure becomes a target it
Caption: ceases to be a good measure so what
Caption: should we do to confront this
Caption: organizational anti-pattern remove
Caption: information silently
Caption: so again having as much broadcast across
Caption: the company around the metrics is a
Caption: great way to remove some of the leverage
Caption: from there ensuring that you have
Caption: metrics that create positive tension
Caption: between an actor's pairs rather than
Caption: skewing towards a single
Caption: outcome those are some of the key
Caption: aspects that you need to first of all
Caption: identify but prevent
Caption: weaponized again focused on changing
Caption: behavior for personal gain rather than
Caption: business outcomes
Caption: so with metrics paper conversations to
Caption: metrics rather than not actionable
Caption: opinions
Caption: customer needs user needs they're
Caption: absolutely your key effective metrics
Caption: often work in pairs and metrics only
Caption: deliver value if they influence behavior
Caption: so in the last couple of minutes that we
Caption: have together what are things that you
Caption: can bring back to your organization and
Caption: how should your thinking be applied to
Caption: certain situations that you face
Caption: yourself in
Caption: and i will i will start with a disgra
Caption: disclaimer here the transition
Caption: between
Caption: delivery and strategic focuses
Caption: is
Caption: super difficult but it is one that is
Caption: worth persisting with
Caption: technical ability is unlikely going to
Caption: be the constraint on the ability to grow
Caption: your career at some point technical
Caption: ability will take you to a point and
Caption: then being able to look more broadly
Caption: around the solution will help
Caption: so invest in truly learning your
Caption: business and industry and that's vital
Caption: to growing situational awareness
Caption: learn the context both within your team
Caption: your department your organization and
Caption: the environment this is a huge step
Caption: change thing for you and embrace
Caption: empiricism it's a great way to level up
Caption: your influencing skills so base metrics
Caption: are the base conversations of metrics
Caption: rather than non-actionable opinions so i
Caption: don't feel x understand how soon do you
Caption: need it when do we need that by
Caption: questions like that can help drive
Caption: concrete answers in that case
Caption: and while you may not always have the
Caption: authority to make a decision you can
Caption: always champion a cause
Caption: work with leaders and other people to
Caption: help push that direction
Caption: and build your network both inside and
Caption: outside work hallway
Caption: conversations incredibly powerful when
Caption: you leave this breakout session talk to
Caption: your peers talk to other people in the
Caption: community and start building your
Caption: awareness of how challenges that they're
Caption: facing and what they're doing around it
Caption: as well
Caption: if you're leading teams focus on growing
Caption: an environment that encourages the
Caption: behavior you want to see and which is a
Caption: quick corollary that if you're trying to
Caption: embed behaviors that run contrary to the
Caption: incentives of your organization it's not
Caption: going to work
Caption: so again making sure that you're being
Caption: authentic to the drivers of your
Caption: business
Caption: so takeaways
Caption: strategy iterative cycle a technology
Caption: strategy exists to amplify the business
Caption: strategy
Caption: looking at models such as 3x at the ooda
Caption: loop could be key to increasing your
Caption: situational awareness around them
Caption: metrics are key driver for delivering
Caption: value and the direction for it but be
Caption: very careful that you're applying them
Caption: in appropriate ways that they're
Caption: actionable and valuable to your business
Caption: and finally go forth be awesome
Caption: hopefully what i've shared with you
Caption: today is helpful i doubt that we're
Caption: going to have time for questions
Caption: so what i'll do before we leave i will
Caption: share the resources slides
Caption: and the reading list which covers a lot
Caption: of the material from today's talk
Caption: what i'll do is questions i'll take them
Caption: at the vix stand just by the coffee cart
Caption: outside and thank you so much if you're
Caption: looking for the slides you can grab a
Caption: picture now thank you so much
Caption: [Applause]